Researching the curcumin in raw tumeric, it turns out that there's only between 3 and 10% of curcumin in raw tumeric root.
So I understand curcumin is considered to be the active form in tumeric.
So tumeric is the root, curcumin is a curcuminoid that's in the, in the, made in the plant.
And that's the thing that studied is the separated curcuminoids in a lot of the studies that are out there.
So when you see curcumin helps kill cancer or curcumin helps decrease inflammation.
Most of the studies are done with the curcumin, they're the most pure form of curcumin, typically the 95% curcuminoids products that are out there.
So next part of this question, in looking at supplements, some of them say standardized to 95% curcuminoids.
So would this mean that if the supplement contains, let's say, 1000 milligrams of tumeric, that somehow they've concentrated the curcumin in the product that there's probably 950 milligrams of curcumin, I believe that's what it means.
But here's the caveat of that. So most of the studies that are done on supplements, like I said with curcumin are is the separated curcumin.
But there's more, more data out there that isn't basically included in studies that the whole food of the product may actually have more value than the curcuminoid portion.
So you can argue with, okay, X amount of grams of curcuminoids have decreased tumour growth, et cetera.
But does that mean that you shouldn't use the whole form of tumeric?
So I am a fan of whole food philosophy, meaning that the way God created tumeric with all the other curcuminoids that are in it.
And all the other cofactors and phenols and alkaloids that are in the tumeric can actually have a synergistic relationship and actually help the curcumin that is in it actually function better.
So I know with this person wrote this, wrote this question because we had spoken the other day and we talked about she uses raw tumeric root grown up and basically she doesn't juice it but she's blending it into a smoothie and I told her I thought that was a better idea but you could search for how many grams of curcumin are in the tumeric root.
And she did so and she saw that only about 10% of curcumin, there's only about 10% of curcumin in a raw in raw tumeric so if you have 10 grams of raw tumeric you're only going to get about 1 gram of curcumin.
Now that is probably true I'm not doubting that but we can't forget that there's synergistic benefits of the whole food so I would not I would recommend that you continue your practice of using the work.
And I would bet if you had a kitchen scale and you weighed your raw tumeric root that you could I don't know how many grams you could get in your serving that you're blending in your drink but if you got 10 grams in your drink, you may only be getting 1 gram of pure curcumin.
But it's a synergistic effects of that that it actually may function as 6 or 7 grams of curcumin in your body so there's huge benefits to whole food nutrition there's so many of the studies on nutrition are from synthesized supplements separated supplementation if you want to read more about it that you could read into western prices work.
I'm very much a fan of that philosophy of the way God created it this is the way we're supposed to eat it and sometimes in the nutritional realms things have been separated out and synthesized and though it can be studied you need much higher doses to get the same effects as if you would have just eaten the whole raw food.
So long answer to I think you should stick to stay with the raw tumeric root.